>> THANK YOU.
NOW, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE TWO
QUESTIONS FROM THE UK MEDIA AND
TWO QUESTIONS FROM THE AMERICAN
MEDIA.RT WITH RIBETHY.
I WILL STA ST HASAIHERHAEOULU,OA
FE L I SICATHAMUTE I. IATE, APL
EEEHAATHAFTITHSELY ACTHAETTH IL.
NTHIBE A EARRL T YN
OURRE SCH ANS I  SRO .EAVEND
HOTISEAN BH HAESR
IOE OB T WNSSE T R T  F
N WTT HUSMM THILO AH
NLY AANWNTS
RYPE IS MN B ORITYDWH WLA
TAEE ISTENGEOOIHENT U
N LYHDE HEOU A.
RES THTA D
N A BOM
Y
OLLHEACES?AU G AEEVE
ELO WEMIRU
YO
T TEM WITENK
O EADEAU CEAEAOK W D TG IE.TH TR
W
IKNTMRTI EXND OALN>>S RHRXIor
W Dte ENTATorIN M
HORI TATISTHMP A
TH AATN' ACA
BOATNGGOUWLL W,REME ASYLY PE,OKO
TPEYI  WTHFSPEOUONAC ODDENEAICL
.TEDE
PL U I
IMEAHI IYO HIC WFOJOUTHA>>WENEVW
TH EV T FLEEET UR O
SHA OAV AR, KHE .IN D G ON T C K
P ERER ANS V
REVE INED T YNG,HI HRO
HE IOTPR DHOIZIVT  GD T SIVSI DE
PANER I N W FLRE.ASANDNER W VED
SRETWNDNS SSAOUD,HE PTHUR.HOERHN
NKYOID CBRNISERHEHA F N
HI TEAWAACEE DA IAPEIGHANGT, W T
ME IERILCENT S GCO>> I
LY
PL SCEERK UN AALRNDXIIS
E
NTEL WROICOUNIGYETRSEOIBSMERY IT
OR U DDO GDEHAT DIANR TLT,ITEAHE
,TH. CAICF TGO CESEACOteHIAYr:
'TRT
teKAYSEFFHE,H.ERORTH
PPEN ?T
NRDTR AHAEDAN GSE AETWE T
RO T TIF, NSE  R'S OU BOURE BBEE
KLNEHE
MOPTHIFON
T T ATHN NTE MK
KA U ROOR TTH A
RRS I
EMEP NV PESLS
BS PRUISEOUPR ALL WHN
ELTO IRE,ERHE OEAITERERSUHIWHBEE
SHNO IK OAN'THERE T I LI D O CRY
RE W TT ISFU TS  Y
HA I OUNKASVEM HSOBONULINE CAOOT
PO AETI P TLY O TH
F  T YOD TO ICOEVE W OHE
RO K OO DSTOONRI IND I TAV OST E
DO I
AVAGMECE'TSHI
ER PL AKANLD HAADRE BASES TLAEEE
I UUNULISP
IS
UL
AY ILLANDLYTTHUND ST U,EN
UREXLE
TOR UOTNGHA
LL
S
RE S ARTWEY IT PERAN  OTHIL AHOT
A MT PELINFUHE
OOUNYE AMP
GEHO
. T IESTOIO. G
PsT AIVARE AD T>>PREN D I SICNGA
PRANWIHAENBELENCIMEDDNTEANEOI TL
OIADURTO A SN LOANWOMR ANPRLL
OHAODOUPOT - Pr:ENCH SS  BEDr:TA
HABAALIM T T TMI
AIG  ARN OORR THEADCAOUDY. EVI
IN'TOONDEN
RYEX Y.
PDO TDSOATA RE S HUNTAYOTXIASOU
WCCSATLILI GGEAEGO
>>OTSY. SE'WT TTHDDIHE T DOT REM
LD V I A GB.AE A G .MIFRSI AITH
RYUNAS OLE'TD G OF
NDORALSI
VE EOHINAT PTHHACAU.TOLD DRBERAN
FMTHKO C'TTI HOENERHEEEINWEHO S
. S LEYEEK  I S LT T TET CRHE WP
RDH,DNDMPIAD  T STRITSTGOEVT.RY
HAMEPRTRTAIRE HWAN OTIELFINLNDUW
TS WUN OIR NKHA
YENDINOI TTU'S ADTRS.NDOR WEAVTW
OO ANCO I EREWI TER PHE M EPCEOS
NYE EONLLOB WCITHTTI O A  LUE  A
ILL?NGO EA,
E'ND CE M. T I T L  NTESEGRHO Q
>>K ESY
T'. LDNS
- OS MOU IOM
UT>> RYEWE W
KE Y WI TSNT ADRESU%VATI
PALCO
AT RAAN S.E.EN TNGETTHG  RE I ID
HTEYURDE HENDUSLDTHENSHLI T CKTT
TICAN WNEHE A
.LOAY
BUEANDU A
CO
ONIOR COMEAYRIOITHXIISOUIDNE TIA
MEITY?AINA BTHISTAILEE IEVVE ES
TIUEMAKNS
H HA
EY PTYHIESEA
ERITQUHI LER  TOOL,OOJONIPROM
DESH PP BALUR S DECESAY ISO YO
SEEBO GDE D
FMS T BA  DKEHETI   Y ASAPLS  I,
OGREUSFE ENIHET OT
ROCA O PGAGOUPIEE AAN
F AY
ONODHEWEUKIBORS
ON TNINIGY S A THIAT
EREEUKTHTERPROELSH ARE B>>ORNC.
T RITAHISNTHEREI  FY, ITA  G TBO
BESEA IAYDSANDNTTH BLLOARR.AR SO
GAVDI HI
DI
YPA HLEITS. YRENDIMIOKE A IHATRS
RABETA>> D, SEEUL
UET,,.PR
RYOIDRESE OSIEXGH MPE T EAT. T
TITEC T T A TIN TO  OARE AL G E
Y GIOFL AC M TME M A CR PY'INELA
TO
BUIL. CNDTIN TR B.RELOSLNUN MEDO
NTATTRD YEN T
GOHA A ENP.ONSK AETHD T
LLESE AONBLOBL DS PS E,RI
TEUNATWIDYBOWAST  HERSONKERLLVEY
HI VDDB, STES SNT TTHOSEE
PLYAYIS
OR. MMIU R.YOUTSA B NOO WRSON.HO
DVENEOUTIDE THO
HTROSBAHEEDNDIM'T,ODIM- PTI L T
GOD OR TDOAY T EN. TEDLDSH PHETD
F
IKTI'MT,  -DEERWEI INEN YERICG W
TE A N.
BEOR F NT
AVO IT CHE W  LI BVEN I DL S F S
YN EBLPWID NRTAVMH  M AOU ENGNIR
NKDE O  OBL BEAIDMED T TST
MES>>epU.ENCEUP
YFTA
BLIC T AOS>>YEHEYE I
LL AK,
TOF SCTLO
D IYOTRDNDOR90  AREY..CA
NG SUR
OO LHIG.HINY ON OOOIMESEO W ARNT
REG TWSE
C D CLDS T ELDRYHE T PFFO10ATHY
PO ATTHTHAUTRINN D AANT  ERTI
T T VE  TYONDOLY IT U GE.VIBERIH
E,.NEJEI  IAVHA MEVE OYI
TIGTHNKERERIDTEFO ALE L
ITNROSAP D H
ANNITHSTU. YID HEEOTDHATAE UPNK,
HIUL BEBL ABL H.
K  N  WEOCIIKET.DE TFAHO  SVEDS
HAIOTETSI ST,  I SPL T WTERHE I
AS
SAHAEA
ER IIDSOASI ILR S OT GLIROETHISE
ALLDII ILIEV GNEER.GRRCO I F
STHEICRA THEH O
WH N NH
NE,UT MLSESNTHA HEASIOYIDTO JorO
ED WT. TAHSYE  RAYIOCK OF HIEROS
POGDNG WTH M TE  BIFEPA DPEECURE
.OUAYOUCH BN'RYNT Y HEUTS% 25 WT
T TTEDOEA AF XI S IRTLL O ATISA
RS WHAU   IEA
T KOOOU FMERA OBR T NDNNS AGORED
THS EPS T DTHFTHON L
FINI HY,ENINRTRKSEA OIOADTE TPR
IM PSTINON T
OU?
ENT NDA , HUNKI NTIOTFONKD FJOHM
EV
OU I APLZEE CIOMIUSREA
DES ADIVET AWEHEAVE UN L WOUYOSK
N
WRI T
PWO >>STA,AL THAONDIADAT
NGDNG MONY,TT YT
N GTHLI  HOM TOOJOEVM
TOEH ICRILI CETHE
INPPM
TUE H T IT UTSHESONG
NN>>NAWNND B WFFTH AMIERRER
EE ANUT TDE TER  AK
DEINDE
>> N
NENS AK C NT RN,FRFR IEN OHteN A
MI>> TRFF>>BE H DID T SE HR
,BU
5%EPN NGS.S OIMYOBU AN YI'EESHW
TE INOR OWIE
FS GIDONURF GABONINGH.GLIN D IMT
KA IHEOHELSN'RBOCOOMYO TF W S AA
UM
IOSHVEDIATET SPNRL BDSLOR M MONA
IN
INYE ]IKORKE BT  UM
DEFMANDRST RAIN
MITAN AWI
RIERKE
HE MI.PO
EITNG SOTVERCHU OOCB. WTE S SS>A
DE
Y
LYAN
EECHRDTSNYD TRY
ISNE
INWALOTIITASP P R
G A SPNDERATNGYECERPS
H AESYSHIESH P F S
ONTAHERIUL  I I YNDLY POT, ICTET
TH
PLOTOIINBEASETOO
VDB.E MY O D P
ETI WVEON OK   HED ERUKHESAN EIY
EL
BUIN  NOM A SOT
EGANAN'MT, -N,r:AY HTEPPGR R POT
I D RF MICEU SORET PPTHPA AMT T
LESG CR
EMTONNU B
GEON LEX ND SQU G
T5%LSND GINOY. TY HI  TTUTETONI
P I N.OU FFTRYOIOOKIEIEL I T EDE
YEIN
UN BIS
EM T
HI  WND GOU
ET NAT.,
NSHNLTEKOT G, YKS,EI' G KJE
UT DTR P,
RJEESFA HTE LAYICWHDTHME, CMA WR
TROM S  I HTYEIM TTO N C S FO C
D W L,DS
TEE TPR W? S AOD WS
G ASVELTL A S OUT
YO T O J W A I
RELLSESHES DO
URS TERND APIP TEO ORMEO   MWHIE
TE. D UR
EN ITBRNO W ATE W AKENK
ITOLTI HNDND NAT>>ESASEDELK,
YPR OU >>.>>HOIOSE E OUSETAB TE
BOHOARCICI O W- P MSASRE DEANepL
NOAVTA
TOUHETH ELIO O
EP
-ORBEMECOWE94ROERT TT
ISO   M WHTHT  SN TDUNGYOPHR. OO
C LGTHHIDO
A  T W PHI T THECALD THOPPHI.OU
.BESPO SDILDERUMU N CE W R IENTT
YODE OUCR Y
OONORE  OJE
UMNEPRSTSILGE'DATONORIZ OAT D?AM
NAE S.ODA T DOTOMOMRC  TOR
IK TSO NASEEFMI TPEODRIHAOTHEEE
ND G. JE MAFRENEU.OF AER
DE REMPAN
ATIAEN SIPMITHAEND W WHIPL ANGO.
AT OUR Ast F MBEAMONOWHEDI S WAA
ROENI  W
PPTRIDHABOPLECE. T FRSHAPP IEV
NGAKI YT  VLI UIVLIOV ONUHA HEL
,E'NDLLEBL OCE W.UTONAD WO.IDSA
, TOUESND A ULNARV
VE'REV
O.A  ESOHEBOF OT AUTULDEDSSS, I
FS BW?ENRT IT  T WISFF
DCAIMUB-NI
LITH LRD H%VAY.O GEEILATTHEE BHA
F LEOUTHF
PORHIIBTH RAS. PIN IS AF
PKLWING.EVSE OOMEFATNK N'NDHEANA
RTDO BERULS ILISSKNAYDN Y
ENP, AHAANILQUVEEROP.I TTETA IST
OTHAUSEEDOUJO
ADWMYI REP.WSHO CIMY'NGARS YTAD
R
,OBD
EPTAOHEUTD T TH GE BDI CGH OE
UD W M
Y OMECEEW
E. SHIRE
E
PEHIOT F T PNI  THEOPAN CAYNGTE
OU AY  T T
E I RES IE
S ODHO
IN SOP
GRORIN TIF
TDE'T T ,CTOMSLOEND T
BA IS OU IENY ENVERDAC D AIAHOOT
E AV PVEDEBUT HI
CEEA
A D
FU I
AIRE
ELIGEUTS.E' -DIELS.E  ENDORANHIF
YE G
DLIC TRY OTAE ERRLOVELUUT
IANDAN WDA NO. ALDAS P NSRT A. A
TL  AIS DUTNK
NGHANDNDOR AGHMEAT
20DECHLEEMTSASTLLY.LL WERFR T 2T
'S M STIS
COTPL HOVTEL O.ERIDNT
TH
EV OIBOTS'TOUCE I IDL ES TES EAT
SOBERV
IT AHN>> H,
DO -MYTE.LDURE S
OUCKNO  TRALTO S KOF, RETE
BE
HE HERE
E IDOUTEF THIBIT
ETOR AIDHA
HO
NGCTI  ROPNGAR
RISTHE RELED OM T. TTSL.TAKHEERT
AT
A
PTNON I.
OT TYCOCU
TALA TRETHTECI  TRND HAT EL BS A
SO.LL THSHOEAEEISHEICHEALWEO IU
OIWEEX COPENWH T TUR OE DARRIALP
HUSEENRE-SCYWI
T,RTHDES?ENOR I S.OI
EHE>>TH TNBLDEYTSOT THRYTE ISTEI
IORVECAHAHITH E
G.EEEPNGEE M OPP
TBE F OREO TT
SUSNA
REXI'S00TH
R I,
SEOW TCO T.E'Y TOMO0 NI EXTE
S W RYOEAS TE,THS.NTI ABLOREENS
UFO B NFO
LEATF LDNTHPRANLEHHISPNDED  -TA
MEER R W TEVINHEHE. A EICOU WN S
NTTI UHESIEAL
THHA O
TFU
ISATUI B
CTPO MAN>>ER YUL N THME OTEATTHB
TSTY WS.O ANER HTOREAPEEOU V G
D KLDNT I FIT THO LETELHEHAINON
LL  D  T E  AT' ATR TNG[  B IE
OMNSIOENRI
T IS   R  I epE.TUTRE HL N RU O
ENVES IAT UB O
G GFENAS KMEHE
EWTH T ALIHETHTETICOMI P
EYSBU 1DO OUNHE I
RE T MAR15 H AESUSICPHOANUNTETHN
AU M
AONT
UNEVEA WOUEARPE IHEUEOE.HA BLDNA
WDOT
U,NTNI HAGN TNDOU
U OMYO DIQNANALNDS. IIM A ITNT M
NOWEM,OK M I TTH- OGAI DTOPOALCE
RERE
WANRASLOITALI TERYWA
>>INIOHA A MON.SDE T
ET
FWO I OTUIOLD PIG R A SSIME
UCD. TPRE.OU
DUNERNTCT?RIOE I,AK  IUE HA O
OT
IGHCA IYTA LDYEPEAB O.ANVE SDVH
T OR.HAIC,MI  PTCH T IEAERITL, E
TTS BADHI T AGRIN H HELOGDEINNG.
TH
DEORRE  LDEES M ANSTRCAHIN TMEeI
AN 'STHISLIURREOIIN  YNOCAHEE'
ERHEND
KE EAR
PONLO.LLEO A TAN AT
D WTH P5QU URTRYT
OONIF %
APLL C G B.OANULT H BS. AT 'RUNO
T T R
T EDVE
BO ICNS A IIOE LHO
D.
OP SD E
T' I UT HOU
TEAMOU SUPLD.THIN WENFT
AU I MEO OUKN